i gotta talk to you bob bruce lee
who's bruce lee to you who is he to the
world what ideas of his
were interesting to you like what
you know you talk about like hendrix and
music bruce lee is that a martial arts
he just seems to have changed the game
yeah
you know i i went as
i guess i don't know the word bold is
the right word to say but i went as bold
as to say
that he was a minor prophet and i got
that concept from the holy quran when it
says that we send prophets to every
nation every
village we don't let nobody not hear the
word in some form
because it won't be fair
and so if allah is merciful
even a man who's deaf has to somehow get
a sign i don't know if moses saw a
burning bush it was nobody else to talk
to so he had to talk to the bush i don't
know it could have been the
bush but point being made
it says that there are minor prophets
and i see bruce lee as one of them
uh because what he brought to the world
through it through martial art
uh was a whole shift in the dynamic of
thinking
you know and that happens when
certain certain entities are born but he
didn't do it only in uh
in the physical sense he was also
philosophizing in the same process
uh
and he was also
striving to be the best of himself so
you got three things going on
i
studied bruce lee multiple times
at first of course
um
when i saw my first kung fu movie it was
the fake it was it wasn't really bruce
lee it was a few green hornet clips
cut together and then i saw a black
samurai then
my following kung fu movies was like
fearless fighters
uh the ghostly face uh
you know to fix the double k but
basically in phillips fighters the lady
put the little kid on her back and flew
across the ocean uh across the lake
right
so bruce wasn't doing that
and then i went on to five deadly venoms
and
spearmen and 36 chambers and these
movies are beautiful
and yet they're all heightened
bruce they're heightened beyond
doable you're not gonna yeah it's like
surreal they play with the world that's
not of this world yeah
bruce played with this world so
when i was somebody when someone i first
saw bruce i actually didn't think he was
as good as these guys he can't fly
he's not flying in the movies right
um but then
when i saw the first one i saw was the
big boss which they retitled fist the
fury
but then when i saw
chinese connection
which is
uh
the real festival right
i saw something different there
and i
got enamored and then of course into the
dragon right just
really complete that's why my first
album was
into the wu tang 36 chambers of shaolin
so it's into the dragon at 36 put
together because those are the two
epitomes
so what happened is you know that's
young me then teenage me studies him
again
and i realize wow look at look at his
physicality
look out for how he's really he's moving
for real
and then i studied him again wow look at
what he's saying
then i studied him again wow look at
what he stands for
which do you like
in the realm of martial arts the the
real or the surreal or the dance between
the two
yeah i'd like to dance between the two
because
a moo i mean a movie to me is to
entertain you
so i'm cool with
obi-wan kenobi
disappearing
out of the cloak
when vader strikes him down
and then i'm like yo what happened he's
like run luke run
i'm cool with that right because that's
the imagination
and the imagination gets stimulated to
the point to whereas things that we saw
imagined by an artist
we strive to create in our real world
thus star trek to me is just a precursor
to our cell phones yeah
so for me uh i like to mix the two
yeah it's funny how like science fiction
like pushing into the impossible
actually makes it realize eventually
yeah yeah we humans like we once we see
idea on screen no matter how wild it is
we we're trying to make it yeah we're
trying to make it it's a young kid it
gets inspired and watch that be like i'm
gonna build that
exactly so i don't know who's going to
come with the back to the future time
machine but uh do you have any
classmates that you think
time machine
uh i thought you were going to back to
the future like the what is it the the
the hoverboard
or like yeah
yeah at least yeah yeah somebody they
got you know they seen the one on the
water no no you know what's close in the
water
it's great it's dope nice it's dope it
actually
it actually if you're a back to future
fan you feel like you made it to to you
made it there yeah all right well now we
just got to work on the on the time
travel
you